the Las Vegas man who shot a waiter in
Chinatown learning his fate today 24
year old Rashawn Gaston Anderson will
spend seven to 18 years in prison as
Kirsten Joyce reports the victim spoke
during today's sentencing
with the assistance of an interpreter
Chen young Wayne explains to a judge
suffering he sustained at the hands of
Rashawn Gaston Anderson on December 20th
of last year inside the Shanghai Taste
restaurant in Chinatown the waiter was
busy cleaning when Gaston Anderson
entered the restaurant Wayne says he
shouted and pulled out a gun Wang was
shot at 11 times seven of the bullets
struck him puncturing his lungs and
stomach his criminal behavior is a very
uh inhuman
Wing survived the shooting but it was a
long road to recovery he spent several
months at the Pam Health Rehab Hospital
working to recover from his injuries I
hope your honor will make it uh decision
and judgment and with the affair and
a clear decision to sentence with this
Defender
now initially Gaston Anderson was
charged with attempted murder robbery
and battery charges but in a plea deal
he admitted to reduce charges of
attempted robbery with the use of a
deadly weapon and Mayhem